thank you
guys
yeah
thank you very much indeed to you Ursula
thank you to you president of the
European commission and to the
European Commissioners for being here
today in Spain's capital in Madrid I
think that this is an excellent
opportunity to
exchange positions align our positions
and talk about the challenges that we
will be facing over the next few months
the president of the European commission
is here today and with me and I would
like to take
oh advantage of this opportunity to
um
highlight what the European commission
has done for all of us in Spain
in these difficult times that we are
going through in the European Union
we are starting the um rotating Spanish
presidency now we
obviously when we we are a member of the
European Union we Implement law we
implement the European law and
um
all work together to protect our
environment to improve our economy to
face the challenge of climate change to
improve our citizens lives in the short
term but also in the medium and long
term
and we are very grateful to all that you
have done for us in the European
commission this European commission has
been able to face these challenges that
we've had head on
circumstances have meant that things
have been very difficult for all of us
I'm
just recalling all of the crises that
we've had to go through together
the long days the interminable nights
when we worked together
to face the challenges of the pandemic
luckily that's behind us um
the war in Ukraine or indeed the fall of
the African government
Spain
is
um it was a Haven for Afghan refugees
particularly women refugees from
Afghanistan
you visited the military base um in
torahan and said that Spain was an
example of the European soul and
Commissioners president of the European
commission is with the same spirit that
we are taking on the role in the
rotating presidency now we have a huge
responsibility we're aware of that
Europe is facing new challenges
within its borders outside its borders
as well and obviously doing nothing is
not an option we need to change we need
to take measures we need to make
progress and it's now under our
presidency that we will have it and it's
the last one during this term of office
there will be the European elections in
May 2024 as you're all aware of course
so this is the last fully operational
for the full length of its presidency
before those European elections we're
all aware of the responsibility that we
should
and the first
thing that I said
to the president of the European
commission and the European Commission
in general is that we will be up to that
job we will be impartial we were
coordinate constructive discussions we
will push forward all of the files that
are still open so that we can conclude
them and as many of them as possible
before the end of December there are
four main areas that we want to focus on
that we think are particular priorities
particularly given the very complex
context that we are in and perhaps I
could just briefly go through these of
four
firstly the present and future of
Ukraine
the Russian aggression against Ukraine
has shaken the foundations of
Europe it's uh awakened a ghost that we
had thought we had put to rest
completely but the European Union will
not budge an inch it will support
Ukraine steadfastly throughout the war
and the long and prosperous peace that
will follow this war hopefully sooner
rather than later we will accompany
Ukraine in all areas of politically
militarily humanitarian and help them in
their path to accession
so Europe and Ukraine together to
together to Victory
I transmitted this message personally to
president zielinski and the Ukrainian
government in Kiev on Saturday
and I would like
to say a few words about the um the
writer Victoria Molina who um who
perished in Russian under Russian bombs
and
she was
a writer of fiction and then she
espoused the cause of Justice may she
rest in peace rest in peace along with
all of the other victims of this
horrible War
another
another thing that another another
challenge that we are facing
is
combating problems relating to supply
the
bottlenecks in in the supply chains
inflation we cannot see these problems
um again the world order is changing and
Europe has to change with it we need to
improve our production we need to boost
our technology ensure our Economic
Security we talked about that the higher
representative and the European
commission talked about that we need to
reach out to our partners particularly
our friends allies and partners the
European commission has certainly done a
lot in that area and what we're going to
try and do in our Spanish presidencies
to conclude some files on
critical raw materials
artificial intelligence such a name but
a few and we will
so we will support a vision a strategic
Vision which we have constructed over a
Year's work with 80 Ministries from 27
member states plus the technical teams
in the commission the Council secretary
act and hundreds of representatives from
the private sector as well
focusing on all of the different things
that the European Union should produce
in a competitive way to ensure that the
green transition and our strategic
autonomy can go hand in hand
launching new trade expansion
taking advantage of the Competitive Edge
that European Union member states have
to ensure that we are at the Forefront
in 2030. so this is our vision which we
will submit to public opinion over the
in the next few days it will formally be
presented to the other EU member states
at the um at The Summit in Granada on
the 6th of October to contribute to
Europe's a prosperity and resilience and
a new European strategy to be approved
at the beginning of 2024.
I think that Europe needs more allies
than it has now Spain is convinced that
Latin America and the Caribbean
should be one of our um
would be an area where we um find more
and more friends and allies there will
be the summer 27th and 28th of July will
be celebrating the links that we have
and building on them
it's something that president vonderlein
has supported right from the start and
hopefully this will be Epoch changing
that will be before and after this
Summit
and then thirdly
we also talked about the green
transition and what the Spanish
government is doing they're very
committed to the green transition this
is one of the main priorities of the
Spanish presidency as you know and the
Spanish executive together with the
European commission we are completely in
line on this we both know that the best
way to combat climate change is not by
denying it or looking away as some
people seem to be suggesting it's facing
this challenge head-on converting it
into an opportunity re-industrializing
our um our continent creating a new
economy and New Opportunities the
electricity Market reform is important
also the fit for 55 for package and the
circular economy will be making progress
on those as well
Spain and the European commission agree
that we need a more competitive but also
a fairer
Society with more um
more solidarity as well so be working on
the mff
reform of fiscal rules
so as to have a sustainable public
finances and to be able to fund Europe
through these two revolutions
the green transition and the digital
transition and not leaving anybody
behind we also talked about immigration
and Asylum pact the Swedish presidency
has done great work in this area I
really wanted to pay tribute to that
what we the Spanish government what we
our country want to do is build on what
what has already been achieved and
strength and commitment so that we can
get a balanced agreement which we're all
happy with and we all where we all feel
comfortable with it and we all feel as
if our needs are reflected a lot of work
ahead of us in the next six months
we are enormously ambitious and certain
that the European commission will
accompany us at every step of the way
the European commission the president
plus the Commissioners will help us to
face these challenges so Ursula College
of Commissioners thank you very much to
you again and welcome once again to the
capital of Spain to Madrid thank you
very much for this visit first of all to
the Royal collection Gallery there are a
museum we're in here today
we had and I hope you too had the
privilege to see so many masterpieces
of Spain's exceptional cultural heritage
time was way too short so I have to come
back because there are so many pressures
pieces of art and culture and history it
was a delightful way to start the day a
day during which we discussed indeed the
European legislative agenda for the next
six months and I also want to start with
Ukraine
Spain is taking the Helm of the
presidency of the council at a decisive
moment when we must double down on our
support for Ukraine
it has now been almost 500 Days
since Russia's brutal invasion
and it has been 500 Days of suffering of
the Ukrainian people
but also 500 Days of impressive
resistance of the Ukrainian people
bravely fighting for their freedom
now it is our duty to match that
endurance
and that perseverance
this includes reliable and regular
financial support
therefore we have put forward a new
facility for Ukraine as part of our
proposal for revised EU budget
it's about 50 billion euros until 2027
for budget and for repair
and we are very much counting on this
Spanish government for government
support for a proposal on the mff
revision by the end of the year
this funding will also support Ukraine's
reform efforts
Ukraine is working hard to progress on
their EU path as you all know and this
despite the atrocious War
so the commission will present the
progress with report on enlargement
and the Spanish presidency will have to
steer very skillfully
these very important discussions on
Ukraine accession path in the fall
on top of this we must continue working
on all other strands to support Ukraine
first the sanctions to keep a high
pressure on Russia
while cracking down on circumvention
second providing the Ukrainian forces
with what they need to be successful on
the battlefield
we have been delivering military
equipment to Ukraine
we have been stepping up efforts to
jointly procure
for Urgent supplies
now we need the Spanish presidency to
secure Swift political agreement on the
so-called act in support of ammunition
production it's a long name in short the
abbreviation is ASAP
so that we can deliver more ammunition
to Ukraine at the same time replenish
our own stocks as well
the third point for Ukraine is on
accountability
today the international center for the
prosecution of the crime of aggression
starts it's a very important work in The
Hague
it is documenting Russia's War crime so
that they can be brought to Justice
and finally in fourth we need to advance
the work on the use of proceeds from
immobilized Russian assets
as you know the commission will come
forward with a proposal
on this soon
we know that Ukraine needs the funding
but also important is that the world
needs to see
that such horrific crimes cannot go
unpunished
this is in very short the agenda for
Ukraine
in parallel of course we must continue
to deliver on our European agenda on our
policy work
and I will start with the
competitiveness of our industry and our
economy
it is the first priority of the Spanish
presidency and rightly so
we can be proud of Europe's leadership
in innovation
but if we want to keep a head start in
the Global Tech race we need to nurture
it we need to improve our capacity to
manufacture Innovation at scale
and we need to send a very strong
message to the industry that Europe is
the place to do business
that's our triple purpose
that's what we have been doing with a
number of proposals
and that's what we need the Spanish
presidency now to Fast Track forward
on the agenda is for example the green
deal industrial plan with the Net Zero
industry act with the critical raw
materials act and more recently we call
it step it's the Strategic Technologies
for Europe platform which is also part
of our mff proposal
our European agenda includes also our
digital proposals in particular the
artificial intelligence act which we
need to conclude
and very important
the agenda includes the reform of the
eu's fiscal rules
we have proposed to revamp our economic
governance framework
so we want to stimulate reform and
investment while ensuring fiscal
sustainability here again we count on
the Spanish presidency to steer and to
conclude it by the end of the year
all this work on promoting our
competitiveness will create good jobs
and it will create growth
and it will make our economy more robust
robust and it will make it more
resilient to risks
in some it will strengthen our Economic
Security
Economic Security is the word that
increasingly is an important topic for
Europe and our International partners
and here too we count on the Spanish
presidency to take it forward the
economic security strategy
that we have presented
not only do we have to use the existing
tools that we have developed but also we
have to discuss new ones and it means
crucially that we need to build strong
Partnerships across the world and that
is where Spain with all its Global clout
can really make a difference
I very much welcome the emphasis the
Spanish presidency puts on trade and
cooperation in the presidency program
we already have an important event
coming up it was mentioned it's the
selac summit
mid-july it's the first
such a summit with Latin America and the
Caribbean since eight years and a lot is
at stake I cannot refer to all the
topics that are on the agenda but most
importantly we want to push forward our
EU mercosua Trade Agreement you want to
push it towards the finish line
we have a key agreement with Mexico that
we want to finalize to so I hear two
count on the Spanish presidency and
finally there is the agreement with
Chile
that is politically already ready to go
so we just need to formally sign it
during this presidency
my last point will be on migration
here the notion of partnership is
Central as well
we've made good progress on the
legislative proposal of The Pact of
migration and Asylum
now we need to take it to the last mile
so that it can be adopted by the end of
this mandate
this is the legal proposal but on the
operational
track measures that we're doing in
parallel work must continue as well
in particular by forging comprehensive
partnership Partnerships that invest in
the economic stability of key countries
of origin and of Transit
in this respect for migration we have
proposed a very targeted increase of 15
billion euros as part of our mff review
all this is crucial during the next six
months so a lot of good work ahead of us
the importance is that are to be
finalized we know that sometimes it's
just the last mile to go but sometimes
this is also the most difficult mile to
go therefore I'm glad that I can count
on the Spanish dedication
the Spanish leadership
and the Spanish deep European Spirit I'm
very much looking forward to the Spanish
presidency
representative
thank you very much president
and I'd now like to open the floor for
questions
thank you very much good afternoon a
question for both
when it comes to the aims and priorities
that you referred to you mentioned the
migration and Asylum pact do you think
that it's really possible to reach an
agreement on this during the Spanish
presidency given the difficulties that
their were during the European Council
last week and what will you do to try
and convince Poland and Hungary
and also was there during the meeting
any comment made or any uh concern
expressed over the upcoming election in
Spain on the 23rd of July and what
impact this may have in a perhaps
negative way on the priorities and
objectives of the presidency thank you
Jose Miguel
on your final question
everything is as normal it's not the
first time that there were elections
taking place in a given country during a
presidency and Spain has been a member
of the EU for quite a while now and has
a lot of experience when it comes to
cooperation with the rotating
presidencies
and all of those discussions and files
will be able to move forward and it is
possible to close them during our
presidency and that will be good both
for Spain and for the EU as a whole
moving to the first of your question the
migration and Asylum Pact
as I said
by way of an introduction I think that
the Swedish presidency has done some
excellent work it deserves a lot of
recognition because the
migration and Asylum pact contains many
aspects that have been successfully
concluded and there it is a topic that
Spain is particularly interested in as
many other countries with an external
border and that's a
flexible solidarity but from the
commission and council's point of view
what we can do during the rotating
presidency is to move forward
constructively and address the points
that are still contentious in order to
arrive at an agreement that everybody
can sign on to
what's important is that we don't lose
sight
of the
challenge posed by irregular migration
and it requires a joint European
response not a response that is the mere
sum of various National realities we
need to tackle the problem together and
migration is a European policy area and
that is why we have to provide a
European response so from the Spanish
side we will work in order to achieve a
balanced agreement between
responsibility and solidarity as we've
already said on many occasions
yes thank you first of all indeed we are
in a crucial point in time
we have to bring a lot of important
proposals across the Finish Line we're
just mentioning a few but all in all
two-thirds of the proposals the
commission has made so far in this
mandate have been concluded but
one-third is still open that's round
about 250 proposals of course not
everything will be concluded but it
shows the amount of work that is ahead
of us and of course citizens expect that
we deliver on our policies
therefore whatever the results of the
elections are I trust that the Spanish
government and the institutions will be
able to deliver an effective presidency
and I have full confidence in Spain's
deep European spirit
on the migration topic
indeed the package or The Pact for
migration and Asylum
the first important parts have been
decided like the treaty wants us it to
do
in qualified majority voting and that
goes also for the other packages
so that's what the treaty says and
that's what we have delivered on
this is the legislative track and I'm
very confident that we will be able to
conclude it because what is still
missing because the atmosphere in the
European Union is indeed that we've all
understood this is needs a European
answer and therefore we want to move
forward together with this legislative
proposal to finalize it on the other
hand there is the operational track
where we are very practical for example
on having pilot projects on the
Bulgarian and Romanian border on Border
management and on Border procedures to
show that it is possible to have fast
and fair procedures at the border and
the aim is everywhere in the external
borders of the European Union you have
the same fast and fair procedure all the
same goes for our external actions so
the engagement with certain countries
countries of origin countries of Transit
where we are willing to invest and to
work very closely closely together with
them as team Europe because we know this
is the only comprehensive approach that
makes it possible to really manage
migration
foreign
there are many files that need to be
completed and I'm thinking of migration
of course but also of the EU budget
review the growth and stability pact and
the files linked to the green deal so
what are your expectations and if there
are no agreements of or if there are not
a good agreement is there not a risk of
helping the population in the next
European election and we are seeing that
the extreme right is rising in Europe
recently in Germany thank you
so I'm confident that we will make good
progress on these important files
because as I said there is an important
momentum right now in the European
Parliament and the European Council and
the respective ministers councils that
we see that only if we stand together as
team Europe only if we really manage
migration are we able to really move
forward in a way that is the most
beneficial for all of us and the topic
itself the same goes for the budget we
have presented an mff review that is
very focused very
um detailed and tailored on the absolute
must that we need because we know that
all the member states have to
consolidate
what are the three topics we are asking
for it is predictability and reliability
in the funding of Ukraine Beyond 2023
this is necessary because when we
negotiated this budget nobody had an
idea that we would be confronted with a
war a Russian war on European soil we
have in the last 16 months dedicated
from the European budget 30 billion
euros to Ukraine that was never planned
in the budget so now all the
flexibilities all the questions are
exhausted and therefore we are asking
for predictability for the next four
years for Ukraine the 50 billion euros
it is also very important because this
is an incentive also for our partners in
the UK in Canada in the United States
when they see that we commit ourselves
they will commit themselves to in a
predictable funding of Ukraine's
economic survival
and the economic governance here too we
have to be done by the end of the year
it's an important file and we know that
it is an improvement if we come up with
a new economic governance as proposed
with all the negotiations that take
place now so I am confident that we will
manage
foreign
thank you a question to both
you talked about uh qualified majority
voting so technically it's possible but
is it politically sustainable to agree
the sign of a migration pact without
um Poland Hungary and also I'd like to
hear from both on you on the
um rise of the uh right-wing extremism
phenomenon across the Europe France uh
Germany uh the Nordic countries in Spain
as well to what extent are you concerned
by right-wing extremism and to what
extent do you think it might undermine
the work that's been done by the
European commission so far thank you
Carlos thank you Carlos
on your second question
it has to do with national
politics and so I'm going to avoid uh
replying to that because this is a press
conference
concerning a biological meeting between
the Spanish government and the European
commission there will be ample
opportunities to discuss this in
upcoming press conferences and I'm sure
in the coming weeks there will be more
than enough opportunity for us to show
our
uh views on this
and on your first question well
political legitimacy is uh given by the
treaties and complying with the treaties
is what gives us that political
legitimate so it's an opportunity to
move files forward that have been on ice
for a long time and there's a real
opportunity that we may be able to
conclude on the Asylum migration pact
and as the commission president just
said it is possible for us to close this
very important file during the upcoming
six months under the Spanish presidency
and I think for spin it's very important
and also symbolic in political terms
Spain has for many years now suffered
from migration crises fortunately over
the last few years the Mediterranean or
the Western Mediterranean route
is
better controlled in terms of irregular
migration flows
and that also
shows the value of the coordinated
migration control policies that we've
been carrying out together with the
European commission it's there's the
external dimension of the migration
policy and cooperation
within Europe but also between Europe
and the countries of origin and Transit
and this is an inspiration that shows we
can make progress and that we can reach
an agreement and Spain has an
opportunity to do so under its rotating
presidency so the migration and Asylum
Pact
and its importance shows how much
responsibility a country such as our
spares
I want to reflect a little bit on your
question what the extremists are
concerned I think important is for us
to deliver on our policies
and I think in a changing world
it is also crucial for us to give
confidence and Security in these times
of change that must be the Hallmark of
our policies
if you look at extremists whether it's
the right or the left they are looking
back
and they fear any kind of change
we the Democratic groups of the center
we have to show
that we have a clear idea
how we want to address change that is
happening
climate change is a fact
we have an idea we have a vision on how
to address it
and how to tackle the difficulties
but also how to tap into the
opportunities
that are for example the new
technologies The Innovation that is
behind it the possibility to show that
you can have growth and prosperity while
cutting emissions
that you can have Prosperity while
protecting nature and the environment
the war that Russia Unleashed in Ukraine
is a fact
and it causes many many suffering much a
lot of suffering and many many troubles
to us
but there's also the momentum in it
that we as Democrats have to show and
that's what we're doing
that we are confident that we will
defend the U.N Charter
that we will defend the international
law
that we will strengthen the principles
that are enshrined for a good reason in
the U.N Charter of sovereignty and
territorial Integrity so we have to
deliver on our policies and show that we
have a vision and an idea how to tackle
the problems of
change that happens but also to turn
them into opportunities
finally a mark peppercorn the false
Grant
work
or not yes now it works good afternoon
thanks for this invitation Mark
baberkorn Netherlands my question is
about enlargement because you both
mentioned uh Ukraine it's not only
Ukraine of course which needs to reform
it's also the EU
now Mr Sanchez you will have this
meeting in Granada in three four months
time so could you maybe share with us
your ideas about how the EU should
reform and then I mean about the size of
the budget where the money is spent on
where it comes from size of the
commission the Parliament and maybe I
could ask the same to Mrs Van Der layer
because especially if you're aiming for
a second term you will have to deal with
it thank you
well thank you for for your questions I
would say that the
enlargement is is on the table
[Music]
this is uh this is true and uh
of course there will be a debate on
institutional reform the resources the
common agricultural policy the cohesion
phones and so on and so forth but I
think the most important question that
we must answer is a
is how do we foresee the European Union
in the coming years
what are the goals uh what is the
Strategic nature of the European Union
in four ten years time
and uh from my point of view but this is
my point of view I do believe that we
need to move forward a more federalized
European union we need to to share more
policies we need to share more
sovereignty and
we need to um
to to find common responses to Common
challenges that also our societies and
countries are facing not only the the
the war its implications
uh but
mainly the digitalization and it's the
transformation of our society and its
impact and of course the climate
emergency so in my point of view those
things are of course important because
at the end of the day we need to speak
about the commission we need to speak
about the seats in the European
Parliament the institutional reforms
especially the resources but what in my
view is more important and this is what
we need to answer in the coming years is
is what kind of European Union we want
and in my view what we need is a more
Federal European Union as actually we
did with the pandemic and with the
response taken by the European Union uh
regarding the the Next Generation funds
I would like to
continue with the experiment you were
just mentioning let's look forward for
years
and try to imagine what Europe will look
like
can we imagine
European Union will be without Ukraine
without Moldova without the Western
Balkan
and those parts of Europe are under the
influence of Russia or China impossible
so
the direction of travel is clear
and therefore now we have to start to
think about how are we making sure that
Europe is
whole
that those countries are part of the
European Union and these are principled
decisions that we have to take we have
to discuss how the decision-making
process will look like we have to
discuss how the common funding that we
have will be allocated what are common
policies that we follow up
and what are the strings we want to
develop in the European Union so these
are very principled questions we have to
ask each other and disreprespective of
what my future is we have to address
them as soon as possible because it will
take us time to come to a conclusion
thank you very much
[Music]